Lo que vamos a hacer en este video es hablar
de los sistemas de referencia, también se les
conoce como marcos de referencia. Los sistemas
de referencia se utilizan en la Física clásica,
en la Mecánica y en la Física relativista; pero
este video es introductorio, por lo que vamos
a referirnos sólo a la Mecánica clásica, a la
descripción del movimiento en términos de la
Física de Newton. En el estudio del movimiento
nos interesa poder describir la posición de un
móvil o su velocidad o aceleración. Para hacer
esto necesitamos definir un punto de partida,
un punto a partir del cual hacer mediciones. Así
que un sistema de referencia es un conjunto de
convenciones que establecemos para medir alguna
variable física. Para establecer un sistema de
referencia en una situación determinada y
poder realizar mediciones, utilizamos los
ejes coordinados, el plano cartesiano, y decimos
que un sistema de referencia es inercial si se
cumplen las Leyes de Newton. Hagamos un ejemplo.
Vamos a registrar la posición de un móvil a través
del tiempo en una tabla. Ojo, podríamos hacer
lo mismo para la velocidad o la aceleración. En
la primera columna vamos a poner el tiempo. El
tiempo puede estar medido en segundos, minutos,
horas o días, semanas o años, funciona cualquier
unidad pertinente. Y en la siguiente columna vamos
a registrar la posición del móvil en diferentes
momentos. La posición la podemos medir en metros,
centímetros o kilómetros, según sea el caso.
En este ejemplo, vamos a registrar la posición
de esta pelota que rueda sobre el piso, un
movimiento en la dirección horizontal. Bien,
ya casi estamos listos, pero necesitamos
establecer primero un sistema de referencia
del que dependerán las mediciones. El análisis
del movimiento de la pelota sólo tendrá sentido
si todas las mediciones parten del mismo sistema.
Veamos con mayor detalle esto. En este ejemplo
voy a usar esta regla o cinta de medir para
poder saber la posición de la pelota, es una
especie de eje horizontal coordenado, y en este
ejemplo voy a establecer que el punto de partida,
el punto en donde el observador se encuentra,
es éste que está aquí, en donde la regla indica
0. Éste mi sistema de referencia. Generalmente
seleccionamos el sistema de referencia utilizando
un eje coordenado en la misma dirección de lo
que deseamos medir, esto simplifica mucho los
cálculos. Te recomiendo que tú lo hagas así
también. Ya tengo la tabla en donde registrar
el tiempo y las posiciones de la pelota, tenemos
las marcas para las posiciones en 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8 , 9 y 10 unidades de longitud. Digamos
que esta pelota se mueve así. Esto se parece a
un movimiento con velocidad constante, pero podría
ser cualquier clase de movimiento, y vamos a medir
el tiempo con este cronómetro. En el tiempo 0
la pelota está en la posición 0, en el tiempo
1 la pelota está a 2 unidades del origen, en el
tiempo 2 la pelota está a 4 unidades del origen,
en el tiempo 3 la pelota está a 6, en el tiempo 4
la pelota está a 8, en el tiempo 5 la pelota está
a 10. Perfecto, esta tabla muestra el registro de
las posiciones de la pelota en diferentes momentos
de acuerdo al sistema de referencia que elegimos,
que indica desde dónde se observa el fenómeno. El
punto central de nuestro tema, los sistemas de
referencia e inerciales, es que los resultados
de la medición de las magnitudes físicas en el
estudio del movimiento de la Mecánica clásica
dependen de la selección del sistema o marco
de referencia. Vamos a repetir nuestro ejemplo,
pero esta vez vamos a cambiar la selección del
sistema de referencia, la posición del observador:
ahora la posición del observador estará a
4 unidades del 0, del origen. Como se puede
observar, la selección del sistema de referencia
y el origen se hace de manera arbitraria. Voy a
agregar una nueva columna a nuestra tabla para
registrar las posiciones de la pelota a partir
de esta nueva posición del observador. Y ya
tenemos las posiciones de la pelota, así que
vamos a ver con cuidado cuáles son las posiciones
de acuerdo al nuevo sistema de referencia, a la
selección de la nueva posición del observador; la
regla graduada está en el mismo lugar. Veamos. En
el tiempo 0 la pelota está a cuatro unidades a la
izquierda del observador, entonces ponemos aquí
un 4, pero, ¿cómo sabemos que es a la izquierda
del observador? Bien, usaremos la convención de
la recta numérica que dice que los números a
la izquierda tienen signo negativo, entonces,
para indicar que la pelota está a cuatro unidades
a la izquierda, le pondremos un signo negativo al
número 4. Ahora, en el tiempo 1, la pelota está a
2 unidades a la izquierda del observador, así que
ahora registro 2 e indico que es a la izquierda
con un signo negativo: tenemos -2. Sigamos. En
el tiempo 2 la pelota está en la misma posición
que el observador, a 0 unidades del observador;
en el tiempo 3 la pelota está a 2 unidades a la
derecha del observador. Esta vez la convención
nos dice que ese 2 es un número positivo. En el
tiempo 4 la pelota está a 4 unidades a la derecha
del observador, con base en la convención, ese 4
es un número positivo, y en el tiempo 5 la pelota
está a 6 unidades a la derecha del observador,
también es un 6 positivo. Y eso es todo respecto
a las posiciones de la pelota de acuerdo a
la nueva selección del sistema de referencia
de la posición del observador. Es muy importante
mencionar que en ambos casos el movimiento de la
pelota es el mismo: se trata de un solo movimiento
registrado desde dos puntos de vista diferentes,
dos sistemas de referencia e inerciales distintos.
El primero coincide con el 0 del instrumento de
medición y el segundo está a cuatro unidades
del 0 del mismo instrumento. Para terminar,
vamos a revisar nuestra tabla observando las
posiciones que seleccionamos para nuestros
dos sistemas de referencia. En el tiempo cero
la pelota está en la posición 0 de la regla,
si lo vemos de acuerdo al observador uno,
está a cero unidades de él, y de acuerdo al
observador dos está a -4 unidades. En el tiempo
1, la pelota está en la posición 2 de la regla;
si lo vemos de acuerdo al observador uno, está a
2 unidades de él, y de acuerdo al observador dos,
está a -2 unidades. En el tiempo 2, la
pelota está en la posición 4 de la regla;
si lo vemos de acuerdo al observador uno, está a
4 unidades de él, y de acuerdo al observador dos,
está a 0 unidades, coincide con la posición del
segundo observador. En el tiempo 3, la pelota
está en la posición 6 de la regla; si lo vemos
de acuerdo al observador uno, está a 6 unidades
de él, y de acuerdo al observador dos, está a 2
unidades. En el tiempo 4, la pelota está en la
posición 8 de la regla; si lo vemos de acuerdo
al observador uno, está a 8 unidades de él,
y de acuerdo al observador 2 está a 4 unidades.
Y, por último, en el tiempo 5, la pelota está en
la posición 10 de la regla; si lo vemos de acuerdo
al observador uno, está a 10 unidades de él y de
acuerdo al observador dos, está a 6 unidades. Con
esto terminamos. Nos vemos en el siguiente video.